in berlin hatten die grünen gerade ihren
allerersten post jamaika parteitag also
quasi gemeinsame traumabewältigung fünf
wochen verhandelt so kurz vorm
mitregieren und dann stehst du mit nix
da und wenn sie sich jetzt fragen was
haben sie denn gemacht da auf dem
parteitag die haben sich in erster linie
selber gut gefunden also richtig gut
dass jetzt nicht übertrieben letzten
samstag von 10 bis 18 uhr haben sich die
grünen da gegenseitig fair gehandelten
honig ums maul geschmiert
unsere sondieren haben einen super job
gemacht und unsere frauen die haben
diese männer runden ganz schön groß wir
haben uns gequält und sind doch
geblieben unsere themen kamen vor
auch wenn das grenzen großes kompliment
liebe freunde und freunde
vielen herzlichen dank ich küsse ihre
schöne augen
sie trugen küssen wie krank ist das sind
tatsache ist natürlich im gegensatz zu
anderen haben die grünen wenigstens
konstruktiv verhandelt auf dem weg nach
jamaika auch wenn er nirgendwohin
geführt hat und dadurch ist offenbar ein
ganz neues grünes selbstbewusstsein
entstanden allerdings im grenzbereich
zum größenwahn und besonders wo sind die
bayern
wir werden hier alleinherrschaft der csu
in bayern stoppen und dann noch
praktische lederhose mit euch die
kontaktlose behalten
fast war mit denen los das hat so den
ins müsli gemüse zur erinnerung zur
erinnerung eigentlich sollten die grünen
auf diesem parteitag das jamaica
sondierungsergebnisse abnicken das ist
jetzt gar nicht gab
ich begrüße von den kreuzberger grünen
dörte hausten geschiedene knalligen
dingeldey sie waren in berlin live dabei
hätte man den ganzen booms nicht doch
absagen müssen
also ganz ehrlich ich fand's eine tolle
erfahrung ja auch im scheitern liegt ja
eine chance und ex axiale noch mal die
haben wirklich richtig toll sondiert das
ganze regierungsteam eine glatte eins
der gem
die kathrin der hubert der jugend die
claudia die angesparte britta
der butendiek anja der ton der will
die taschen ja britta schon zwei mal
artig ok ja ja sorry
natürlich dürfen wir uns auch feiern ja
wir grünen sind wenigstens eine
erwachsene partei wir übernehmen
verantwortung also würden wir ja wenn
man uns lässt aber man lässt uns ja
nicht ja noch nicht erfreut wenn es in
vier jahren wollen gibt dass wir dann so
stark sind dass keiner mehr vorbei kommt
und das ist egal ist was die anderen
treiben dass wir einfach in die
regierung kommen und da muss sagen dass
es getan wird was notwendiges danke
[Applaus]
der mann ist echt ne ja weil für mich
ist eindeutig kanzler material der toni
sagt wir grünen sind die letzte
handlungsfähige linke partei
deutschlands und genauso ist oliver
offen punkt letzte linke partei haben
die grünen haben die grünen nicht gleich
beim aller ersten sondieren die
vermögenssteuer aufgegeben
vermögenssteuer interessiert unsere
wähler anne ist ja die interessieren
sich für jahns anderer sachen das ist
ein insektenhotel
da können angreifer und so weiter sich
zurückziehen wunderbar nachkommen
bekommen und haben dann bessere chancen
auf den baum zu klettern und dann sich
die ganze kleinen blattläuse tisch
nachts schlaflos verliert also ich fand
es echt nicht okay dass er findet die
geschichte von dem ohrenkneifer nicht zu
ende erzählen ja ja ja wir brauchen sie
ja nie so blöd zu kicken sie backpfeifen
gesicht wir sind alle jenes insekten
sterben ja aber wenn es darum geht wie
kommt denn der ohrenkneifer an seiner
blattläuse da steinmeier reist ich aus
dittos traurig ich find's einfach mutig
bin auch traurig keine frage jeder mag
ohrenkneifer aber hätte man in berlin
hätte man in berlin nicht mehr über die
zukunft der grünen sprechen müssen
sie könnten als kleinste
oppositionspartei demnächst zwischen afd
fdp und linken regelrecht zerrieben
werden könnte könnte peking ente
na klar müssen wir uns jetzt neu
aufstellen ja aber das machen wir ja
hoch ab januar kommt ein neuer
vorsitzender uli robert habeck dieser
kleine kita und drehen dann der hoch man
kann so oder so auf soll weiter gucken
aber aus tierschutzgründen kann man
sagen das hätte die chance gehabt eine
echte schweine koalition zu werden
schweine koalition oder einfach so raus
wenn er ankommt wird alle juden naja der
habe oder nicht es muss ja eine
richtungsentscheidung geben setzt sich
jetzt der kretschmann also der pro
auspuff flügel durch oder rückkehr noch
weiter nach links
klar da grübeln drüber nach yahoo aber
meistens noch zehn sekunden camburg mehr
und träume lieber vom habeck dem hengst
verlag ist nicht dabei sein
wörter haus geboren
[Applaus]